welcome to this video playing Jay and
drew don't know that guy nope new
account nope it's got like five thousand
three minute games and I never played
them yeah really a huge player pool
let's see can I do something else maybe
hmm about the check benoni the check
benoni now maybe not pre move on I have
to be cautious with the primos yeah this
leads to a closed position quite
obviously we are maneuvering assume it's
very important let's see Bishop to e2
was eerily angling for something no
something strange hello like g4 or
something he just wants to play in a
very classical fashion with one short
castle yeah good idea my plan is to play
G 697 and f5 ultimately now this is
related to to the Kings Indian in some
way and at least him he's taking quite
some time be three years kind of
mysterious I mean if you want to play on
the queenside you normally do like a
three and before
yeah I mean without f5 my position has
no point whatsoever so let's do that not
really sure what what is his ideas here
with with this yeah maybe Bishop g7 96
yeah that must be the idea
oh ok I'm wondering yeah I mean it's
hard to prevent push up to 17 g 796
check bishop be 6 d is six Chan ok
yeah efore would be the normal reaction
now probably probably form that all
looks kinda weird I mean not like we're
didn't in bed but we don't understand
what's going on this whole way is
playing he's playing that is kind of
strange Quincy one and those kind of
moves okay so still this Bishop g7 96
business and maybe Queen g3 is coming
okay maybe Queen to g6
he's taking quite some time
yeah 97 96 now I'm aware of that but
it's very difficult to do something
against it queen d 8 backers and maybe
just back and kicking away with a six
this kind of play is really weird queen
bee three now
what does this account he's got 3,000
games right now this is a cheating
account simply this is just a total
cheat this guy you can look at it look
at this yeah this is this is just a
cheetah account they're all game smelts
yeah I mean pretty obviously with b3
Queen c1 this is very computer ish and
look at those crab ratings yeah in
comparison he's got 2,300 here in the
pool yeah and he's got 15 minute is so
and so yeah but the rest of it yeah one
minute is 1800 blitz is 1700 which is a
total catastrophe I mean really this is
1700 in blitz is equivalent to 1500 five
minute yeah and so I come on give me a
break here come on here you get this get
the point blank resins and now let's
let's check how this correlates to
engine would be would be would be cute
so I have a look at this no person in
his right mind plays be three in this
position it makes no sense whatsoever
yeah and I'm actually doing something
now which I don't do normally yeah here
I cannot do that I cannot can I do that
let's let me do this do you see the
stock fish evaluation yet stockfish
wants to play be three in this position
yeah this is total nonsense this move it
makes no sense whatsoever but it's a
computer move the computer does not
understand this this closed position
okay this is funny so let's say I know
that the screen is kind of screwed up
but i just want to show you the the
correlation with the engineer I had the
feeling during the game and now we will
see how it is identical just that you
see that I'm not talking nonsense Bishop
h6 stockfish naija seven the next move
Queen d2 is what stock fish is giving he
plays Quincy one it's maybe a matter of
time but he plays him
and five it takes and takes 95 or the
compound Knight f6 yeah now we will f
form yep here we go f1 con move before
yeah what was the next move Queen to e3
I guess right maybe takes a moment he
took its time we played them I'd be five
and surely here Queen d3 and Ti assembly
was fed up with it well moves like the
moves that indicate the computer here is
the move B 3 this is very typical
because this is a typical move of the
comp that doesn't understand the closed
position any human player wants to play
on the queenside would want to play a 3
before may be prepared by rook be one or
you would do something else like 91 2 d
3 this is a human maneuver I know that
at the moment the view on the board is
obstructed but let me I can switch this
back yeah and this is this these are the
moves that you see from computers those
b3 is completely useless move and he
never followed up on that yeah he didn't
fianchetto or anything I mean maybe I
mean the fianchetto would be pretty
pretty awkward yet but it would be
connected to the move B 3 yeah but he
didn't he just failed Bishop h6 which
does not relate to be three at all and
g6 was totally obvious that this is my
my next move this is the idea behind 98
@ g 6 now you don't play be three if you
don't want to play we should be too yeah
and the next funny movies is this one
well maybe he's using another engineer I
just have stockfish 5pm but maybe if you
take what no Houdini huh Komodo they
will come up with Quincy one this is
also a move that absolutely no human
would ever play what is the point of
Quincy one if you really for some reason
yeah feel that this Queen should belong
on this diagonal which is kind of weird
anyway but if you feel like it you would
play Queen d2 obviously why would you go
to see one and let's say
keebler rooks disconnected it doesn't
make any sense the typical mysterious
computer move yeah then a 595 this is
kind of normal at saya but all this like
f4 and then well and the Queen III not
be found this this is totally computer
ish i was i was already suspicious after
the move b 3 because any human player I
mean it could be a move by somewhat
weaker inexperienced player but if you
have such a rating in five minutes
you're pretty decent player normally or
you a cheetah em in this case this guy
is a cheat if you don't believe it you
can write it in the comments pits I'm
totally sure and i will send a message
message to ICM well thanks thanks for
watching we're just there was curious
normally I don't upload those games but
I thought it would it was interesting
maybe to discuss the points like B 3 and
so on I have those kind of games once in
a while and there are not many people
cheating but this was one of them thanks
for watching